your your intellectual toolkit needs to
be full of adjectives metaphors models
and possibilities and then you can say
of DMT well it was like the Sistine
Chapel altar except that instead of the
kind of light you get in Caravaggio or
somebody like that there was a kind of
you know the sort of thing the pious
grew involved is doing in his
resurrection where he and well if
somebody doesn't know what any of this
is they're having a kind of DMT
experience just listening what what do
you say was he saying what what but if
you know what you mean and speak
precisely I mean all these words have
meaning you know Sistine Chapel altar
light like Caravaggio modified as the
way grew and evolved and did it and so
forth and so on so somehow bite and it
was it's still an incredible flattening
I don't mean that this is an adequate
tool I mean it's a tool I am perfectly
aware that the most high flown and
hysteria provoking descriptions of DMT
I've ever been able to summon up in
front of a group were complete betrayals
is the real thing so so so not what it
was that the word lie is almost
applicable but it was the best it's the
best I can do and that's why I have said
this morning you know this idea of
building the Internet as a net for
capturing the alien mind if we go into
the internet and I build
weirdest and most mind-boggling virtual
reality I can imagine and then turn it
over to you and you come in and add your
filigrees adumbration zkk eupolous and
what-have-you and then we hand it over
to you and you do the same by now this
thing has gotten pretty weird
just this intensification of weirdness
slowly we can build up an image of it
but I don't think that a single person
could possibly have the breadth and
depth of experience to do it alone I
mean maybe a Thomas Pynchon or some
someone like that but we're involved in
a communication struggle here we're
trying to describe the unspeakable we're
trying to to literally move the
boundaries of what can be said and what
can't be said we're trying to push the
frontiers of what can be said deeper
into the domain of the unspeakable and
are we succeeding or failing well that's
for each one of us to judge I know every
time I smoked DMT the first emotion I
have as it fully established it as it
fully establishes itself in my sense or
Hamm is that I have the sense of
remembering what it really is and having
this sort of guilt / embarrassment about
realizing how hideously unfaithful I
to the truth of it this truth can't be
told at least not by me I've been trying
for 20 years and I have created an
object in discourse that fascinates
people but is it DMT no it's it's me
doing the best I can